- Let's give a warm welcome
to our next moderator,
Tom Green.
(audience applauds)
- My brother's on the cheese,
my brother's on the cheese.
What's up ComicCon?
How we doing?
Are we going to
party here tonight?
You ready to see the
Workaholics out here?
(audience cheers)
That's not loud enough.
Let's hear it a
little louder here.
Let's make some noise.
My brother's on the cheese,
my brother's on the cheese.
Yeah.
Let's bring out the
Workaholics one at a time.
Make a lot of noise.
Anders Holm, come on out here.
(audience applauds)
Blake Anderson,
come on out here.
Adam DeVine.
And Kyle Newacheck,
come on up here.
Let's make some noise!
(audience cheers)
- What's up?
(mumbles)
- I'm very sorry about that.
This is very exciting guys.
It's so great to be able
to talk to you today and
interview you guys here today.
- I want to get to
know some people.
- This dude is just eating.
Hey, check out the dude in
the corner just eating.
- Get it boys.
- Hey, what are you guys eating?
What is it?
- It's a sandwich.
Give it up for sandwiches!
(audience cheers)
- This Comiccon panel
goes out to sandwiches.
- So guys, when you're in
a situation like this, you
started out you're friends.
You started the show together
and now you've got this tit
show and now you've got all
of do you pinch yourselves
sometimes and say look at this,
how did this amazing thing
happen?
- We pinch each other.
It's a game we
play when no one's
looking and I just
told you guys about it.
- It's a late night game.
A very, very, very late night
game that we play where we pinch
each other until we bruise.
- Yeah, it's the morning
actually if it's that late.
- That's how late it is.
No, it's super, crazy surreal.
Well, Roseanne Barr
just came up to us.
- Yeah.
- Like 15 minutes ago and
was like my kid is a big fan,
I have no idea who you
are, but my kid is a fan.
(audience laughs)
And that still was very cool.
- I like how on that show,
remember how they switched out
the Becky's on us?
- Yeah.
- Like we weren't
going to notice.
That was the coolest shit.
- Who's team Leesie?
Team Leesie?
The first one?
- No, 'cause she's the
first one, original.
- Yeah, Sarah Chalk.
Chalkie?
Chalk?
- Nah, not me.
- This is our transition into
saying we're
switching out Carl's.
- Yeah, we're going
to flip out Carl.
- Goodbye.
- It's going to
be Louie Anderson.
- Yeah!
Family Feud!
- I think it's a step up.
- Every week it'll change.
Tom will give you an ep as Carl.
- You like Carl?
- That would actually,
that'd be pretty good.
- You'd make a great Carl.
- Now, you guys all
still live together?
- No, no.
Thank God.
- No, you're not all living
together anymore now that the
show's a hit, you all moved
out to separate houses?
Or?
- Yeah, we just moved.
Blake and I lived
together up until
about four months ago.
Which is weird.
People were like you guys are
gay dudes together, right?
(audience laughs)
You guys are gay dudes.
- No haha.
- Which, it's a
lifestyle you know?
Don't judge us.
We so finally just moved on.
But we lived together for like
seven years, and before that,
Kyle and I and Blake all lived
in the house that we shoot
Workaholics in.
Which was a very
weird first season.
We're saving a lot of money.
- Yeah, that was so weird.
- We were convinced, oh we'll
do one season, get canceled,
and 'cause we're going to
say tight butthole on TV and
they're immediately
going to cancel us.
- Nobody's gonna like it, yeah.
- And then, oh, some
tight butthole fans.
Okay cool.
(audience applauds)
- Tight butthole.
Keep it tight.
Who would have known?
- Hey everybody here is a
tight butthole fan, right?
Yeah.
- Put your hands up if
you like tight buttholes.
- Hands up if you
like tight buttholes.
- See mom, I told
you they'd like it.
- Told you.
I don't think that's
going to catch on.
- Now what is the back
story behind tight butthole?
- It's actually pre-dates
the existence of Workaholics,
which is even weirder.
- Well, you know
Lisa Ann, right?
- Yeah, it's based
on her butthole.
It was, we were talking about
how people say like tits
instead of cool, which
just seems like, you know?
- Which is disgusting
by the way.
- Yes, inappropriate.
- Chauvinist.
But it seems arbitrary.
It's like yeah, tits are
cool, but you can say anything
you can say tight butthole
and it's like maybe we will.
- Wait a second, wait a second.
- It still gets me too.
- What's the, wait a minute,
so you write the
show together right?
How do you do that?
Do you go sit in a room
and go through ideas?
- We sit in a room
just like this.
It's the exact same
size as the room.
- With rats and cereal and
we just josh each other.
- So much joshing.
It's a lot of joshing.
- Yup, non-stop joshuas.
- Has anyone ever had like
a hidden camera reality show
where the host is named Josh
and it's called Just Joshing?
- That's gotta happen.
- Well, it's mine.
I said it here.
- Where's Josh Gad?
- He's got a tight butthole.
- I think you're
saying it out of,
that's not the proper context.
- I invited it so I
can say it how I want.
- Yeah, I think you're supposed
to say like something is
tight butthole, not the
specifics about his actual anus.
- Gross.
- But what are we to do if
we really want to explain how
actually tight
someone's rectum is?
- It's a tight rectum.
- There we go!
- Josh Gad, tight rectum.
- And he is, tight butthole.
- Yes.
- Okay, I'm catching up.
- And, coming this fall,
he'll be joshing you.
- That's a good idea for a show.
- Kyle, was it hard
directing these guys?
- Yeah.
It's the worst.
These guys are divas.
- Scuze me?
- No we're not!
- It's a lot of fun.
Honestly, these guys are my
best friends in the whole world
and we get to work every day
together and we just get to
make each other laugh.
- Awww.
- I'm sorry, I'm
totally going to cry.
- You said you wouldn't cry.
- I didn't mean to.
I said I wouldn't
cry, but fuck it man.
They need to know how I feel.
- Are you really crying?
- It's hard keeping the has
your friendships improved
since the success of the show?
Sometimes it's hard,
the pressures of fame.
Has that changed?
Anything?
- Oh yeah.
We're so tight now.
We like buy each other ice.
We don't wear it, it's strictly
around the house kind of
stuff like Drake does.
- Well, no new friends,
he taught us that so.
We're stuck with each other.
- No new friends.
I'll meet all of you, but
as far as friendship goes,
staying right here.
- Not gonna happen.
Sorry guys.
- It is pretty cool though, I
don't know, we've been doing
this a while, we started off
doing YouTube videos together.
- You guys heard of YouTube?
- Yeah, have you
guys heard of this?
It's a website.
- You guys heard of YouTube?
If you've heard of
YouTube, say yeah.
It's amazing.
- Great, I like how only
40 people said yeah.
Everybody else was like
I'm not saying that shit,
obviously I know about YouTube.
(audience laughs)
I obviously know
about YouTube, Tom.
Come on, Tom.
Yeah, I mean it's cool that
we get to go to work with
our best friends
and write a tv show.
So, it's, thank you guys
so much for watching.
- Yeah, thank you.
- A lot of word play, a
little bit of writing.
- Yeah give yourselves
a round of applause.
- Yeah, honestly.
Actually, we'll clap for you.
- It's the same 40 people.
- Yeah, there's not a
lot of participation.
- What's the biggest
change, you start out making
YouTube videos, you don't have
a big budget, now you have
this big network budget, what's
the biggest change when you
got all this money to spend
on the show and stuff?
- Well, we could turn
you into a Cyborg.
- Yeah, did you see your laser?
- The laser beam sword.
Light saber.
- Now we can do that.
Before we were putting like
cryptonite locks on our
necks and we've elevated to
cool things like laser swords.
Everyone should have one.
- Yeah, but it hasn't
changed that much.
I mean, we still kind of
attack the comedy like we
did when we started.
- Damn right.
- We're still grinding guys.
Hard.
We're grinding.
You're going to get in
trouble over there lady,
I'm hearing everything.
Aight?
I'm going to bite your
nipples off, girl.
You watch it.
- That just got crazy
violent very quickly.
It went from like someone
might ask you to pipe down
to I'll bite your nipples off.
- I'll bite your nipples.
- Woah dude.
- Cool your jets.
- Hey Blake, how you feeling?
You had that accident, you
jumped off a roof and hurt your,
everyone heard about this I'm
sure, but how you feeling?
- I feel great Tom.
(audience laughs)
- Well, he broke his back for
those of you that don't know.
- Yeah, snapped it.
Whoopsies!
- Yeah, he's got that like
Dr. Octagon spine now.
- I do.
I feel great though,
thank you, Tom.
- How exactly did
that happen though?
- I can't remember everything,
but I remember falling.
- It's like the Tom Petty
song is based on it.
- Yeah, Freefalling.
- He went back in time.
- I was such a bad friend and
roommate too because he was
like I think I might have
broke my back and I was like
no way.
I'm like here you just
chill out, go to bed,
I'll keep partying and then
we'll look at it tomorrow.
- Just drink a bunch
of Nyquil and shut up.
- Chug this Nyquil
and go to bed.
- Take these sleeping
pills, never wake up.
His words.
He's putting on a
face for you guys.
He said that.
I was there.
- I didn't say that.
- He's an evil drunk.
- I didn't say that verbatium.
Yeah, I'm a murderer drunk.
You know how like you get a
friend that gets like dumb drunk
or crazy drunk?
I murder people.
- It's cool.
It's like little shop of
horrors, but with your friends.
It's like feed em people.
- Yeah it's like a
Dexter situation.
I only kill other drunks.
- What'd you say bro?
- What'd you say?
- Hey jump off that roof.
- I fucking will.
- Whoopsies!
- Maybe I will.
- You didn't get it
on film, did you?
Jumping off the roof?
- No I think it's on YouTube.
- You've heard of
YouTube, right guys?
If you've heard of
YouTube, say yeah.
- Alright!
- Wow, so some people
Googled it and alright.
- Yeah, the word is spreading.
- Maybe by the end of this
panel, everyone will know what
YouTube is.
That's cool, we learnt.
Who would've thought you
came to Workaholics and you
learnt something?
- We're here to teach.
Save your money, Google YouTube.
- I'll bite your nipples off.
(audience laughs)
- So you're writing
the next season now?
- Yeah, we are.
- Any surprises?
Anything you can let
slip now, or is that
not the way it works?
- Well.
- We could but
- Let's give people a little
tidbit about what's going to
happen next season.
- There's a lot of
chicks this season.
- Oh Yeah, the chicks.
- So dudes, get ready.
- The guys almost
get laid this season.
- The dudes are
getting hella sexual.
- That's what happens the
more we go on, we're like we
should have some more good
looking girls on set, right?
What if like the dudes hooked
up with a ton of hot babes?
- That's funny stuff.
- Wouldn't it be hilarious
if like Adam would just sleep
with a ton of babes this season?
- We're off doing the
adventures, like meanwhile,
(moans)
- That's a good impression.
That's how I do it.
I drop in.
- What are we going to do?
Alice is going to be here?
(moans)
- I don't move anything
else but my nose.
- It sends sonar waves down.
- Oh man, that guy
bangs like a rabbit.
Literally.
- That's cool.
So that's this season.
- Yeah, there's a lot of that.
- We're kind of, I mean,
we're still in the middle of
writing everything, so we
don't know who will like guest
stars we're going to get.
But, if I had to guess,
Denzel Washington, probably I
don't know.
- Probably.
- If I had to guess, Jamie Foxx.
I don't know.
Like maybe.
- Taraji Henson?
- I don't know who that
is, but definitely.
- She's good.
She's good.
- Celine Dion maybe.
- Possibly, we don't know.
We haven't casted yet.
- There's no way to tell.
- More than likely,
none of those people.
- Yeah.
- So don't get your hopes up.
- And just some like sketch
comedian friends that we have.
- Safe bet.
(upbeat music)